Google Sheets lets you
collaborate with others
to organize, track,
and analyze your data,
whether you're using the
web, Android, or iOS.
Sometimes it's hard to import
data from other sources
without considerable
manual work.
That's why we built
a new Sheets API.
We want to save users time by
enabling richer connections
between other tools and Sheets.
Let's see how it works
by reviewing integrations
built by two of our partners.
Sage, a leader in accounting
and financial software,
has found an
innovative way to let
small business users customize
their analysis and reporting.
They've used the new
Sheets API to allow
users to export a spreadsheet
packed with charts and analysis
in one click.
After a user tailors the
spreadsheet to their needs,
the data is kept in sync
with Sage so users only
need to set it up once.
The new Sheets API makes
it easy for partners
to create always
in-sync reporting that
uses the rich
functionality of Sheets.
Next is Anaplan, a
popular cloud planning
tool that connects enterprise
business planning and action.
Anaplan recognized
that users want
to collaborate with others to
inform better decision-making
across the enterprise.
And that collaboration
is at the core of Sheets.
As a result, they
built an integration
that allows users to
easily share their latest
data with Sheets, collaborate
with others to receive input,
then push select changes
from Sheets back to Anaplan.
The new API can be
used to empower users
to collaborate around
their data from leading
applications in Sheets.
Partners can then
automatically import changes
from Sheets via the
API or let users choose
when to push select data back.
This new Sheets API
is available today,
enabling developers to build
rich integrations and workflows
around Google Sheets.
These integrations, along with
those from our other partners,
will be launching in
the coming month, all
working to save users
considerable time and effort.
Visit
developers.google.com/sheets
for more details.
We look forward to
seeing what you create.